good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm gonna
try to do this without a script so the
other day I was talking to a YouTube
friend of mine who also has OCD and they
were like how do you seem so put
together which is weird because at the
exact same moment I was thinking the
exact same thought about them anyway the
answer of course for both of us is
editing like you hear me say good
morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm gonna try
to do this without a script but like
what you don't hear is this good morning
good morning good morning Hank it's
Tuesday so the other good good morning
Hank it's Tuesday so the other day good
good morning Hank it's Tuesday so the
other day I was talking to a YouTube
friend of good morning good morning good
morning good morning Hank it's Tuesday
so the other day I was talking to a
YouTube friend of good morning good
morning that goes on for about 2 minutes
and 40 seconds so like this is real I'm
in my real basement right now and I'm
going to really edit this video and
upload it but it's also inevitably a
construction like I'm picking this frame
by the way why are there so many new
boxes and if we move to the frame just a
little bit you would see that like most
of the basement is toys it's almost
impossible to remember on like a
second-by-second basis that when you
watch a youtube video or you look at
people's social media feeds you're
seeing a curated version of those people
we talk a lot in the youtube age about
authenticity and over the last decade I
have tried to be authentic but in
telling the truth you choose among many
true stories which true story to tell
right let me tell you two stories both
of which are true last week I went to
VidCon Europe and Amsterdam and it was
awesome and amazing and I had such a
good time true also true I was
infuriated with myself that I wasn't
able to do a signing because of these
problems I have in my brain in on
photography Susan Sontag writes about
the Farm Security Administration's photo
project in the 1930s she says the
photographers would take dozens of
frontal pictures of one of their
sharecropper subjects until satisfied
that they had gotten just the right look
on film
the precise expression on the subjects
face that supported their own notions
about poverty light dignity texture
exploitation and geometry making videos
even ones that don't feature your face
is often a kind of self portraiture as
is your Twitter or your Facebook it's
you but it's also framed and images are
just so incredibly compelling like we've
all had the experience of reading a
novel and imagining the characters in
our own minds and then seeing a movie
adaptation and having the images we
imagined to be replaced by the actors
but an image is just that it is
the thing itself this is not a pipe and
this is my life but it's not all of my
life and if I can remember that about
myself maybe I can start to understand
it about other people by the way over
the 100 days channel I made a video
talking about my OCD in much more detail
if that's something that would interest
you link in the doobly-doo below and
remember the next time you see an
Instagram photo that you're super
jealous of somebody framed that shot as
indeed we are all framing our lives Hank
I'll see you on Friday